hatte der 16-jährige schüler jeremy
heraus essen der einen amoklauf am don
bosco gymnasium geplant hatte einen
komplizen jetzt hat ein
spezialeinsatzkommando eine wohnung in
einem mehrfamilienhaus im essener
stadtteil borbeck gestürmt kurz darauf
fuhren die polizisten einen jungen mann
in handschellen ab auch ist die wohnung
von einem sprengstoffspürhund durch sehr
interessant der einsatz soll im
zusammenhang mit dem verhinderten
anschlag auf das don bosco gymnasium in
essen und stehen die vom sek gestimmte
wohnung liegt nur knapp einen kilometer
von der besagten schule entfernten die
beiden jugendlichen sollen brisante chat
nachrichten ausgetauscht haben und wir
sprechen jetzt über die hintergründe zur
festnahme mit unserem chefreporter frank
schneider in essen frank was wissen wir
denn über den jetzt festgenommenen
jugendlichen und kennst du vielleicht
schon inhalte dieser brisanten chat
nachrichten
der inhalt war eigentlich sozusagen
bildlich problematisch denn der jetzt
festgenommen oder vorläufig
festgenommene junge mann er soll ein
bisschen älter seines jeremy er hat
fotos gepostet von waffen und aufwand
anhand der fotos konnte die polizei
nicht feststellen so handelt es hier um
scharfe waffen oder eben nicht scharfe
waffen und daher eine pumpgun eine
maschinenpistole sowie zwei weitere
automatische pistolen gepostet hat ist
die polizei natürlich sehr elektrisiert
gewesen und hat natürlich sofort einen
einsatz eingeleitet weil man konnte ja
nicht ausschließen dass möglicherweise
ein weiterer schüler irgendetwas plant
und daher auch nur einen guten kilometer
vom gymnasium entfernt und dort heute
die schule wieder begonnen hat wollte
man gestern auf nummer sicher gehen und
nichts riskieren
aber es gibt die erste entwarnung es
handelt sich bei diesen waffen um
sogenannte softairwaffen das sind diese
waffen die mit luftdruck kleine
kügelchen verschießen die sehen aber nun
mal leider sehr echt aus es gibt ja
mittlerweile auch in den gesetzestexten
die sogenannten anscheinswaffen weil
teilweise mit solchen waffen auch
überfälle begangen werden man kann also
diesen unterschied wirklich kaum
erkennen beim ersten anblick und
deswegen auf den fotos nicht und da
wollte die polizei kein risiko eingehen
deshalb auch der einsatz des
spezialeinsatzkommandos gestern und
junge mann wurde dann in anstellen auch
mitgenommen aber in der nacht noch
wieder nach hause geschickt er geht es
jetzt weiter wie laufen jetzt die
ermittlungen weiter frank
naja die ermittlungen hat ja gestern die
bundesanwaltschaft übernommen und das
ist ja ein ganz klares signal vorher
lagen sie bei der
generalstaatsanwaltschaft bei der
zentralen terror abteilung aber jetzt
hat es wirklich noch mal die
bundesanwaltschaft übernommen und das
spricht eben für besonders herausragende
tat und da spielt sicherlich rein dass
er so viele bomben bauen wollte was im
einzelnen diese bombe wirklich
angerichtet hätten er wollte hier eine
splitterwirkung mit nägeln erzeugen wie
schlimm sie wirklich oder wie verheerend
diese wirkung gewesen wäre wird aktuell
von experten des landeskriminalamtes
geprüft auch das bka unterstützt
mittlerweile und der generalbundesanwalt
prüft eben ob es sich dann nicht doch um
möglicherweise einen der größten
rechtsextremistischen terroranschläge
gehandelt haben könnte dir geplant
wurden denn es wurden ja bei jeremy ganz
eindeutige indizien dafür gefunden dass
er rechtsextremes gedankengut hat er hat
über farbige er hat über ausländer
muslime auch über juden gehetzt er hat
gesagt das einzige sinnvoll ist sie zu
töten und da gab es eben sehr sehr sehr
viele aufzeichnungen auch auf seinem
computer eine wird ein word-dokument
worin er ganz klar geschrieben hat dass
diese amokläufer auch zum beispiel der
breivik in oslo der alleine so viele
jugendliche und kinder erschossen hat
auf dieser insel utoya für ihn vorbilder
sind und das ist natürlich verheerend
man muss aber immer wieder sagen es
handelt sich offenbar auch um einen
psychisch kranken jungen mann bei jeremy
und möglicherweise brauchen hilfe und
wir können alle nur froh sein dass die
schüler so sensibel reagiert haben sind
zur polizei gegangen die polizei hat
sehr schnell reagiert und diesen
schrecklichen anschlag verhindert kennst
du denn familiäre hintergründe von war
vor schon irgendwie auffällig
eben überhaupt nicht und das ist ja
eigentlich was die sicherheitsbehörden
auch so beunruhigt und auch so alarmiert
wir haben das in jüngster vergangenheit
immer wieder erlebt wir hatten ja zum
beispiel auch einen jungen mann 16 jahre
alt er einen islamistischen
terroranschlag verüben wollte auf eine
synagoge in hagen und auch da gab es
vorher keine erkenntnisse dass war
reiner zufall dass ein ausländischer
nachrichtendienst chat-nachrichten
abgefangen hat wie er mit dem gs
ausgetauscht hat die hatten ihn per
instagram angeschrieben und hier ist es
zum beispiel so bei jeremy da gab es
überhaupt keine vorkenntnisse
das ist ein junger schüler 16 jahre der
in seiner dachgeschosswohnung bei seinen
eltern sitzt und solche irren dinge
plant er hatte auf einer tafel zum
beispiel sogar klar aufgeschrieben wie
er die bomben baut welches
mischungsverhältnis was er beim ist an
nägeln und solche dinge und das ist
extrem beunruhigend weil die
sicherheitsbehörden natürlich auch sagen
da sind jetzt möglicherweise viele
jugendliche die die im einsamen sind die
möglicherweise verrückte gedanken haben
die sich im internet radikalisieren und
anstiften lassen und wenn wir die vorher
nicht auf dem schirm haben sowie die
polizei das immer nennt dann ist
natürlich unglaublich schwierig hier war
das große große glück dieser zeuge der
sich an die polizei gewandt hat und dem
das wirklich zu gefährlich wurde und der
ist wirklich ernst genommen hat und die
polizei eben zum glück auch sofort aber
die gefahr besteht natürlich dass nicht
jeder etwas verplappert denn hier ist ja
wohl so gewesen dass jeremy auch
andeutungen vorgemacht hat und dadurch
natürlich die mitschüler sehr
sensibilisiert waren und das gefühl
hatten da stimmt was nicht ihr geht's
mit jeremy er weiter er setzt weiterhin
in haft
genau er sitzt jetzt in weiteren
untersuchungshaft und jetzt muss man
eben prüfen sein anwalt möchte das auch
prüfen lassen ob er nicht in der
psychiatrie besser aufgehoben ist das
hat sicherlich über gutachter genau
prüfen wie stark sind seine psychischen
erkrankungen möglicherweise er hat ja in
diesem manifest auch nicht nur gesagt
dass er andere menschen töten will
sondern dass er selber auch sterben will
und sein hass sei nicht zu bändigen hat
er geschrieben und hat eben auch
geschrieben das leben macht für ihn
keinen sinn es ist sinnlos es ist
erbärmlich also sein eigenes leben hat
er auch gehasst und dieser selbst hasst
führte möglicherweise auch zu dieser tat
und deshalb muss man jetzt genau prüfen
was sind die motive und man kann
wirklich nur für diesen jungen menschen
hoffen dass ihm geholfen werden kann
dass sie mir psychologen helfen und dass
er vielleicht in ein paar jahren ein
normales leben führen kann vielleicht
noch ein satz zum strafmaß dieses so
genannten vorbereiten einer schweren
staatsgefährdenden gewalttat ist nach
jugendstrafrecht mit maximal fünf jahren
bedroht das heißt also je nachdem es ist
ja zum glück nichts passiert wirklich
schon dass er vielleicht mit ein paar
jahren davon kommt und dann wie gesagt
über hilfe von psychologen
ein relativ normales leben dann doch
irgendwann führen kann 16 jahre alt
jeremy vielen dank frank schneider